what's really happening in 2020
democratic polling um III think that
it's kind of early to do daily updates
about the Democratic primary polling I
think it's too early even to do weekly
updates but I do think that every couple
of weeks it's worth checking in on
what's going on with 2020 primary
polling because we're seeing some pretty
interesting shifts and most notably and
don't shoot the messenger I'm not a beto
supporter I'm just telling you what's
going on
Beto O'Rourke has been surging since his
formal announcement and he's doing
really really well in terms of
fundraising as well we'll put up a
variety of different polling on the
screen for you I've already said I don't
see the appeal of Beto as a candidate
but if you look at the Beto or Rourke
polling over the last several months you
will see a definitive upswing since he
announced that he is officially a
candidate you also notice that Joe Biden
who still has not announced his
candidacy is holding roughly steady he's
still leading in basically every poll
sort of polling between 26 and 35
percent which is pretty significant if
we look at a different sort of slate of
polls you will notice all of the exact
same trends Bernie Sanders also holding
roughly steady ranging between 17 and 27
percent notably Elizabeth Warren has
kind of been trailing off you will see
that Elizabeth Warren in pre beta
O'Rourke polls was as high as 13%
she's now polling as low as just 4% and
as high as 8% her campaign just uh sort
of struggling to get going also I'll
call your attention to Kamala Harris
who's been trailing off a bit in the pre
beto polls she was in the 5 to 17 range
she's now not polling higher than 12%
anywhere so I don't know what else we
can we can sort of say at this point in
time Pat other than we know that
historically the person that is leading
in March of the year before the election
does not end up being the nominee that's
important to remember but otherwise I
don't know what else to make of the
polling other than
some people are having a hard time
getting their campaigns going yeah the
beta thing is interesting I would not
have guessed that I don't see the appeal
but that's for me personally I could see
that some people for they may think that
beta reminds them of Obama he is a very
similar cadence and demeanor and maybe
they just want to go back to those old
days that's exactly why Joe Biden is
leading most of the polls right now I
think based on what we've seen in the
past two years from the Trump
administration people just feel
nostalgia for that time they want to go
back to the Obama era and I think Biden
and Bates he'll offer them that people
I'm sure will be pointing out that
Andrew yang doesn't appear in any of
these polls that's true I mean he
nationally he's not polling one percent
in just about any poll he says in Iowa
he's making some impact although I
haven't seen that polling he's gonna be
back on the show next week
and speaking of which let me know what
you want me to talk to him about I know
some people have concerns over Andrew
Yang's UVI plan some people are
concerned about Andrew Yang's opposition
to college tuition being paid for
through taxes so he will be back next
week if you have topics that you want me
to broach with Andrew yang please let me
know I'm looking forward to talking to
them today's program is sponsored in
part by control center by kaavo which
simplifies your home theater so you can
control everything that's connected to
your television with one easy-to-use
remote with voice control you can plug
in your sound system cable or satellite
TV streamer your game console and
Control Center will control everything
for you no more fiddling with different
remotes
weeding through search results to get
the content you want one universal voice
remote control controls it all so say
what you want to watch let Control
Center handle the rest it'll take your
at home entertainment experience from
being stressful to being very simple
enjoy what you want when you want it
easily I have it connected with my TV
sound system and DVD player and it has
simplified everything shop now get 40%
off control center with the promo code
Ackman that's 59.95 a 40% discount from
the normal price of ninety nine ninety
five service plan required first 45 days
free control center is available at CAA
veoh.com and best buy control center by
kaavo one remote that does it all